I want to get back. I want to get back
to my routine. Hopefully strict
discipline spiritually and physically.
Hopefully start exercising, eating
right, getting to church. I need I need
to get back. So, I'll be here till
Tuesday, Lord willing. So, we'll talk a
little bit about the show about part
two.
When we finished part one, Patrick David
had asked how long would I be here? I
said I'll be here till Tuesday.
and he asked them what his schedule was
like. So the only availability he had
was Wednesday 6:00 p.m. Florida time
[clears throat] because he was going to
fly out Thursday.
He travels everywhere. He wanted to do
part two. However, the spiritual warfare
was so bad.
I have never experienced spiritual
attack and backlash like I did last
week. It's been years. If I've ever
exper experienced this level of attack,
it's been years. I haven't undergone
such spiritual attacks like the week
leading up to this event. So then
Wednesday comes, I get a call.
Patrick Bedav couldn't make it because
some issues arose.
So he flew out yesterday, meaning part
two won't happen. But here's the thing.
They told me, thank you, brother. They
told me he's never done a part two with
someone and he wanted to do it right
away. He even looked at me saying,
"You're going to be here Tuesday? You're
not leaving? Is my schedule open? Glory
to the triune God. Glory to the Father,
Son, and Spirit." They told me he has
never done a part two with anyone.
So, he wanted to do a part two with me.
Okay. Glory to the triune God. Oh,
one of his uh staff members confirmed
they will do a part two, Lord willing.
They will do a part two, Lord willing.
But to be frank with you guys, even
though I'm Sam, I want to be frank right
now because we are in Florida anyway.
So, I want to be frank,
okay? Whether he does part two or not.
Okay, let me remind you guys.
Whether he does part two or not,
it doesn't matter.
Here's the thing, though. Whether he
does a part two or not, I'm just saying
demons are manifesting because I'm going
to show you some stuff on Twitter.
You have to
really I want to emphasize this. Really,
I want to emphasize this. I really want
to emphasize because I don't think
people take me seriously and some people
may think I'm put on a show.
The world does not need any of us. The
world does not need any of us. Right?
I'll open up the Q&A a little later, so
be patient.
You do not need David Wood. You do not
need Patrick with David. You don't need
me. You don't need anyone. The sooner
you realize you don't need us, the
better off you'll be because,
God forbid
scandals break out, as you can see,
they're trying to accuse me of stuff,
defame me, but God will deal with them.
And he is he's exposing
to get me deplatformed, and God doesn't
need me or we're going to die. And
Christ will still be building his
church.
church. One thing I'm already feeling
down about is because the attention this
is going to bring me. The tension that
I'm not looking for, right? Why? Because
to be in this field when you get
attention, you're going to have people
idolizing you, which is a sin. May God
destroy every form of idolatry and
blasphemy. Then you're going to have
people who want to bring out dirt to
discredit you because you're a threat.
They can't refute you. Then it brings up
your family issues. Then it brings up
my experience. Now I want to put things
in perspective. Why did I go public and
mention my situation with my ex-wife?
Okay, let me put things because people
have selective memory.
People have selected memory. Selective
memory.
The reason why I had to go public
and I couldn't cover it up is because
if you've ever been through a divorce,
and I hope you haven't, your court files
will be on record,
public record, and they can access them
unless you ask for them to be hidden
from the public public record. I need
you to listen.
I knew
I knew even Mike's wife can testify that
the Muslims will try to find any dirt
and they'll find
my [clears throat] court documents where
they try to demonize me and make me look
bad. Now, I'm a public servant. What
does that mean? I'm here wanting to be
used of Jesus Christ to serve the church
as imperfect as I am.
Right? and I depend on the grace of
Jesus to stir up hearts to support the
ministry financially. So because you're
here supporting me, I have to then
explain myself. And you see
since the divorce
which was when was it
when was it finalized? I don't remember.
I think 2018 was it
they have been taking my court documents
right
right have been accusing me of being a
white beater white beater right all
right for years I've had to deal with it
so I had to go and explain what happened
now what that means is my ex-wife will
be shamed my ex-wife will be exposed and
humiliated now remember my daughters are
with my ex-wife.
My daughters are being raised by her.
Anything and everything I say,
eventually they're going to be old
enough they're going to hear this and
watch this.
And so, no one comes out a winner.
Nobody.
I don't come out as a winner. My ex-wife
doesn't come out as a winner. And the
ones who get damaged are my daughters.
My daughters have already been through a
lot. And sadly, it won't end until Jesus
comes. Jesus returns and saves us and
forgives us and heals us. So this is the
world we live in. One thing I try to
make clear
on earth. I love my daughters the most.
On earth I'll die for my daughters and
be killed for my daughters. On earth.
On earth. I love them the most. I want
to finish leaving them a legacy.
providing for them financially and die
in their arms for the Lord is pleased
and then be forgotten.
So now notice this will never never go
away because people don't understand
your present actions will have future
consequences. When you flippantly send
text messages to try to demonize
someone, those text messages don't go
away because when people turn on you,
they will then use those test text
messages set said in anger to demonize
you, right? That now you regret to then
throw back in your face, which is what
happened with David Wood, Marie Wood.
That's what happened. I've been as
honest as I can. May God forgive me.
May he save me from lying. And try to be
as honest as I can.
But people don't understand. In the fit
of rage,
you will say things that you think do
not have future consequences.
No. Once it's out there and text, that's
it. Unless the person changes their
phone or deletes their messages and go
nowhere.
And if people turn against each other,
then they're going to use the past dirt
to then shame you, demonize you,
discredit you because that's all they
can do, right? See that?
So, we have to keep reliving this. But
if we relive this, the ones who are
going to get hurt are my daughters.
They're going to find out about this.
They're going to be crushed. You
understand my point? So from now on,
everything has been said. So I need your
prayers in this because I'm weak. I'm
not strong. What I want to do, I don't
do. Right? What I want to do, I don't
do.
The things I don't want to do, I hate, I
do. But here's where I need you guys to
pray for me. Here's what I need you guys
to pray for me.
Ask God to bring me in because I don't
want to talk about my ex-wife anymore
and my situation. It's done. You've
heard it all. I've given you receipts.
I've told you the facts. They can lie
and defame me about something I didn't
do. Right. Great. That's a lie from the
pit of hell. The Lord will deal with
them in time.
It's done. Here you go. By the way, I
just told Mimi Nikab.
I said, "Hey, Mimi, Nikab, I'm the one
who's been calling you out to debate.
I'm the one
that's going to end up ending your
career." Nikab, I've challenged you to
debate and we'll make it happen. Now,
don't run like Aisha did. We have the
tweet. So, now let's see if Mimi Nikab
is going to make a thousand excuses like
Jacob did. Jake, remember?
Now, Farida got upset at me, too.
I said, "Amen. Jesus is burying Muhammad
under his feet and he's going to bury
these daad dogs under his feet. Damn, I
look fattier.